If you're not united within yourself and
you need to be united in relationship to
a higher purpose to be united within
yourself,
then you're weak and the world will take
you apart and and and the reason it
takes you apart,
I think as partly because life is,
is rife with suffering and it certainly
bounded by mortality and those are very
grim fats and unless you have hammered
yourself together to find a destiny
that's of sufficient nobility so that,
that the so that those negative elements
become tolerable,
then the suffering will take you apart
and,
and demolish you.
And so it's not optional.
This is you might say,
well,
what does that have to do with God?
And I suppose that depends on what
you're,
what,
how you interpret God,
but it certainly at least has to do with
the finding of a transcendent purpose.
So,
and you do that through consultation
with yourself.
You know,
and you're yourself,
and this is a kind of a way of looking
at things that,
that curl you can develop your self that
I'm talking about is the higher self.
That tells you,
for example,
when your pursuit of impulsive pleasure
has demeaned you or or interfered with
your proper motive being and people
understand that experience very well.
You don't have to talk to someone very
long until you can discover what they're
ashamed of.
For example,
like why be ashamed if you aren't doing
something that demeans you.
Why have contempt for yourself if you're
not missing the mark and with and the
fact that you have shame and self
contempt.
He indicates that there's something in
you that striving beyond what you're
currently investigating and and for your
libertarian types,
like I would say,
look,
you don't have to Kowtow to an arbitrary
external authority,
although often there's use in that from
a disciplinary perspective,
but I could say just as
straightforwardly and usefully that your
viewers and listeners could merely stop
doing what they know themselves to be
wrong.
Forget about what anyone else thinks.
It's like you know when you've
transgressed against your,
your being and we we could say,
well,
you have an ethical.
It's an ethical necessity to limit the
transgressions,
transgressions that you can identify
against the nature of your being,
and I don't see that that's a disputable
point.
Unless someone can step forward and
claim.
While I never feel any shame and
everything I do,
I believe to be 100 percent right.
It's like get away from that person
unless they're the Buddha.